welcome that was the intro song welcome
back me man thank you so much Jenna
covering me last week unfortunate stuff
I missed I missed podcast last week it
was the Jenna cast and I first of all
you guys have been so supportive this
last week we can happen it's made it's
made things easier for me but Jenna you
really held my weight what what I love
you thank you so much for for covering
me last week it means a lot and I have a
question though yeah do you like my
outfit
what tell me tell them what you said to
me before we came in here I need a
sweatshirt really a hat or something cuz
it's Sunday right now for us and I'm
just like in full Sunday mode like
haven't put my contacts in like people
always make fun of me on the podcast
because I just always look so blah but
it's cuz it's usually on a Sunday when
when we're doing this so we working on
the weekends y'all so I'm always like
full comfort mode you know anybody yeah
I would dare to I would just get way too
hot
but look at me yeah you gonna be high in
like 20 minutes
no I feel fine and my son Carmen really
likes this outfit Oh your son is well
he's weird
anyway this episode is brought to you by
the skin guys there's so much confusing
information out in the world the skin
makes it so easy to digest with a
compact nice little morning newsletter
writing your email inbox it's free it
comes every morning alright but I got to
do is go to the skin calm that's th e sk
IM m calm slash Jenna Julian you get the
the information you need to dominate
everyone at work with information you'll
be the most knowledgeable person and the
most humble you also are entered to win
a $250 Visa gift card when you use that
URL or click the link in our description
also guys texture the the way to read
magazines in 2018 you're not gonna muddy
up your old house and bathroom and
yukine coffee table with with physical
magazines who the hell does that alright
you're gonna get texture okay someone
living in the past
yeah that's live in the past access to
over 200 premium magazines all the ones
that you like guys time the Atlantic and
New Yorker Vanity Fair variety I think
which you were on the cover of which is
so cool anyway guys you can get texture
for free you can try it for free right
now go to texture comm slash annejulien
that's texture calm slash annejulien
and or you click the link in our
description and give it a shot it's
really cool way to Romanians thank you
sponsor thank you see how long she'll
sit here she's being pretty good she was
pretty cuddly today yeah it's kind of
bored though oh yes she does oh well she
just looked at you like that are you
okay oh we're gonna play a we're gonna
play a game is similar to nuclear winter
but it's not nuclear winter we're knit
we're naming it something different
because of the scenario we've made for
this one is different
well because nuclear winter is really
fun because we like to see although you
wrote all of these I wrote all
this is the first time that I haven't
had to make up for you covering my ass
last week sweet butt so the premise of
nuclear winter is that we pick like
professions and then descriptions
ridiculous descriptions out of a hat and
they get paired up together and then you
have a bomb shelter and you can only
keep like 10 out of the 15 combinations
or whatever so you get rid of the people
that you can live without so it's like a
doctor but he farts fire and like random
stuff like that but if you're in a bomb
shelter and you need to like survive for
the foreseeable future you know you have
a strong inclination to keep a doctor or
something
so we've liberated ourselves I guess
from the the need to keep some people
maybe based on the their profession by
making this more like survivor based
survivor is it space I don't know the
two the two network execs you didn't get
on the same page before the meeting okay
well I guess it could fit for any like
desert island scenario and also space at
we call it is it space or space survivor
okay we gotta bring in the ratings there
they're just they're just like people
with different characteristics so in one
ball there's characters and then the
other ball there's characteristics so
we're gonna make people by pairing their
final yes correct
but we're gonna get rid of them one by
one like survivor based on whoever is
probably the most annoying people who
don't want to tolerate living with we
gonna get to the the ultimate survivor
yeah yeah there's gonna be one remaining
one will come on okay for the for the
journey okay wait but I thought we're
all in space we're we're kicking them
out of them the shuttle yeah oh that's
terrible
we're sending them a new vacuum well I
feel like if it was like a survivor like
we're running low on food like where we
have to decide who to eat sweetie them
yeah we also have to take it
in consideration who would taste good
okay so is this space survivor or is the
survivor space survivor okay and we're
eating we're eating the people we're
eating well we can either eat them or
just dump them okay okay so if we're
really hungry choose something to eat
but we don't have to eat we can if if
we're kicking these people out we're
whittling it down to one well it doesn't
matter if we eat them because there's
only gonna be three of us at the end
there's gonna be plenty of food oh my
god okay forget about the whole eating
thing is I'm very uncomfortable base
survivor we're your friends no we're
getting rid of them or we're like
launching them off of a trampoline into
space but let's pretend they would work
in space a pretty desert desert island
planet like a pretty one with water and
like he's like Mars no Mars doesn't like
that
like one in Star Trek where they you
know they land out and Sutton like
suddenly the batter is totally fine for
them to breathe it's called Saturn
Springs that is the sister planet to
Saturn that no one knows about because
this is the best-kept secret in that in
the vacation world mm-hmm
that's where Palm Springs got its name
okay Saturn Springs okay so we're going
to Saturn 80 degrees is very hot okay
you have to prime yourself for the
weather okay how does one prime
themselves for the weather Sand Springs
cough you'll find out okay okay okay um
so let's create this scenario we're
we're we're on a spaceship we're all
going to Saturn Springs I say we all get
there but every week we have to decide
somebody that leaves Saturn Springs
that's that's fair at the end of the day
we're not on earth mm-hmm we are just
with these people it was angry of a
population of humans with us right so
this is it but Jenna's approps yeah and
we're we're on the show also there's a
reality show are you bored I think she's
at a reality show it's a reality show
but nobody's watching it because
everyone's dead we're the only ones on
No if everyone's dead then we wouldn't
kick everybody off we would need to keep
the whole posture that's true I keep
changing the rules just it's a reality
show host by Jeff promote Lee how long
are we it's like it's like 15 years it's
like the truth it's like The Truman Show
and everyone's watching us from Earth
so there's but that's okay okay that's
so in the movie The Truman Show we are
being we are their subject of that TV
show yeah like yeah and there's it's
like Big Brother sort of okay that works
but they're watching this remotely from
Earth and we have to vote a person off
every week yeah I like that
and then we're basically in theory gonna
get to top three because you and I are
also unsafe course unless you know me
and one of them just really decides that
yeah all right here for the right
reasons okay I'll go first ladies first
it's Aries season sorry season y'all get
prepared for lots of spontaneous points
and things caught on fire speaking of
fire our first contestant is a guy who's
on fire who does the orchestra
conducting finger thing when they pee
like he does that when he pees many PC
so he pees without holding yeah it's
just going everywhere okay I think that
being on fire is probably worse than
that but okay literally nothing's
working being on fire I don't know how
he's on fire I don't know how he's been
on fire for so long I peach okay he's on
permit I get perma fire
all right their next contestant is a
beekeeper who's lost his way and won't
stop talking about how cutting out
caffeine has me gonna feel so much
better
okay oh good
all right he's a contender okay well he
carries good dude he's a keeper so he
cares about living things he's a good
guy he seems like he might be
compassionate but he's also he wants to
share some positive things with people
that's true that's true he might be a
nice person that's true all right well
okay an erotic novelist who won't stop
saying wig and oh my god me in every
conversation that's not true I literally
said that to you as a suggestion because
I was on Twitter and I was reading
rickey dillion tweets that character is
basically rickey dillion oh but I love
Ricky yeah he might get voted off okay
we never Ricky back on the podcast it's
been ages okay I had oh my god
hey MA Matt Damon but he stuck in the
makeup from stuck on you so he's
attached to Greg Kinnear they
uncontrollably steal people's toilet you
not want the stuck on you boys taking
your toiletries they're gonna go for
your Dopp kit and there's nothing you
did cuz there's two of them that's a
problem I need my toiletries they need
it more there are two people Wow [ __ ]
those guys
Oh easy there our national treasure a
freshly divorced dad with nothing to
lose yes lose dandruff is Parmesan
cheese delicious that's pretty helpful
honestly I like I don't see a problem
with that
he's just out here trying to rediscover
him yeah he's got nothing to lose and
his hair is jeez
alright Michael Keaton squeezing into
his nearly 30-year old Batman outfit
Julian and he gives constant updates on
how well there's make sure 30 years
almost 30 years so we basically have
Batman
pretty much just like stalks he's like a
full of himself
old Batman except instead of like
fighting crime or doing anything just
belittling you for your stock choices
and raising himself up man that's not
not looking too it's not looking good at
all
a retired porn star who won't stop
reminiscing about quote glory days who
every night after 10 p.m.
can't understand how gravity works clock
hits dead whale points are a female porn
so it doesn't specify you wrote it it's
a retired porn star I know no gender
so do they just freak out in the media
10:00 p.m. the clock hits 10:00 and most
times they can carry on but if you try
to have conversation with them or if
they ask you why they're not floating in
mid-air they don't they can't comprehend
it till the morning man that's that's
brutal so every night every night is
hell pretty much okay a youtuber who
does candle reviews ooh
but instead of reviewing the smell they
review how bad they sleep yells in
Dothraki
professionally birds themselves and
sleep yells in Dothraki I mean it's a
pretty good language to sleep Yellin if
you're gonna sleep y'all you got to do
it in Dothraki I think oh my god so
between this person and that person we
have two people pretty much pretty much
it finer can we get any sleep oh this
one's bad this is the one that you
but it's a bad one and putting them back
I mean it's a bad I thought I'd delete
it but it's not deleted oh so you want
to put it out of this yeah maybe we'll
see yeah yeah it's not good okay not
it's not bad guys just weak I'm a strong
one
this next one is a brain surgeon who
runs on a human-sized hamster wheel 20
hours out of the day I had his chest a
disturbance
I mean wait so he can surgery the other
four I guess so when does he sleep Kylie
Jenner's baby's future baby
so Stormy's baby yeah Stormy's future
baby who smells like pistachios and lies
about everything
do you I don't know why you're asking me
that's that Stormies deal okay no it's
stories babies daughter or son probably
daughter oh my god how far in the future
is this we're gonna be dead we're not
even on here no no
all right karma is making you so hot no
okay dick Jonah Hill who doesn't believe
doctors are real people okay all right
thank Medusa's do you know there's a
website oh this is Jonah Hill fat and it
updates um so I found it I know it's
really [ __ ] up but I found on reddit
someone actually has the domain it's
almost uh I think I was like if he's in
shape or not so let's uh you know that's
a website though the Internet is a wild
place all right a racist farmer who
won't stop sniffing their fingers and
laughing afterwards oh no we can't have
this person racist Fozzie I made that
exactly that way because he could be
helpful but he's racist racist get out
of here boy
too hot literally 103 degrees exactly on
the dot
I'm an electrician who shakes your hand
but with their finger in the middle
tickling your palm obviously not the
worst yeah I know that like that really
bothers some people but it doesn't
bother me too much
plus you're not going to shake hands
with them all the time it's true except
he likes shaking hands that's why I
wrote that hmm interesting
all right a pickup artist
gross who demands a fortune cookie after
every single meal what a guy
how obnoxious what a guy what else you
got a Jehovah's Witness on his bicycle
who misses his mom so much so much so
much honestly not bad
pussy's mom she's got a bike I don't
blame them I wouldn't miss my mom too
we're in space but he misses his mom all
the time
that's fine so much all right a sex
doctor who won't stop accusing everyone
of cheating on the test even though
nobody is even in school okay sounds
annoying mm-hmm an orchestra conductor I
messed that one up
yeah an orchestra conductor who is an on
the fence flat earther but we're on the
fence okay could go either way at this
point all right and the last one is an
IT guy who refuses to believe churches
are real okay like church is not not
like religion like just the physical
locations are even okay okay right so
who are who are our definite get outs um
racist farmer let's get him out of here
but we up wait hold on oh we're doing it
like week by week
okay so week one do we alright alright
Hoosiers that is like you you need to
get out mmm well I I don't see a need
for a a person who is a brain surgeon
and be someone who is gonna be on a
hamster wheel for 20 hours out of the
day like a human sighs how could you
even like interact with them you mean he
might be able to talk to you all he's
running but like imagine how much that
guy has to eat that's true just to
maintain that schedule yeah I mean if we
have limited resources
he can't be burning eighty eight
thousand calories a day because he wants
to yeah why does he need to be on a
hamster wheel just how he exists hmm
okay yeah but he's not looks like how
some people do yoga for one hour a day
he does that for 20 solid comparison yes
thank you I feel like a racist farmer
that won't stop sniffing his fingers and
laughing afterwards is like enough but
you know what he's laughing about he
could have the answers to all of the
wonders of the world by sniffing his
fingers that's why he's laughing no I'm
just being devil's advocate here okay
you're not gonna do come here come come
he come he's my frontrunner to get out
first okay
Hoosiers on my cider in total on your
side um who's the brain surgeon he's
gonna be one shaking my hand and
tickling my palm I hate that it's like I
hate it when you do it but if a stranger
did it I would definitely so that's your
worst one yeah yeah yeah I don't want
the electrician I want
oh but he's an electrician could be
helpful I feel like a racist farmer it
needs to get out first let's get him out
of here put him in the barn so we put
him in the ball we're eliminating the
racist farmer who won't stop sniffing
their fingers and last time next time
don't be racist keep sniffing your
finger though that's fine
that is fine that's fine honestly it's
fine
okay I take it back it's not right
Kermit I want you to soothe me when I'm
so hot bud it's just so hot all right
you pick the next one to get picked up
okay um stop sniffing your finger so I
think um the orchestra conductor yes hay
is probably really pretentious that's
actually I just prejudge that guy you
might not be pretentious at all but the
thing about being it on the fence flat
earther
I think that's gonna piss a lot of
people off especially when we're not at
home
on Earth Day so whatever doubts he had
he now no longer has because he's seen
the fact that we're on into their
[ __ ] plane well we don't know that
he's not quite rational hey we're
podcasting don't make noise ki he's
looking at I like it
oh he's sweet he loves me okay so that's
your next one I don't like to fight with
her I don't like the flat earther why
well because he's a flat earther yeah
but I feel like okay I see where you're
going but people that won't stop
stealing my toiletries that are two
people that are gonna fight me all day
on this one because I am keeping those
boys I die those guys those guys
together are my hero wait so they're
just like two little hamsters and then
they hoard everyone's toiletries
hamsters yeah they're not hamsters
they're cinema legends in character of
their masterpiece
hitfilm stuck on you by the Farrelly
Brothers I can't get rid of them
well no definitely not on the second
round I'm keeping them are you kidding
me diamond care okay you know I'm a fan
of both of them as actors individually
but if you're gonna put them together
and put them in costume this is like
teasing me with a sequel but I get to
meet them I don't care
they can have my toiletries about your
next one getting voted off it in sorry
well
the guy on fire seems to pose a threat
just based on a safety purpose like if
he's on fire and he's lived this long
while being on fire
I'm sure he's developed some sort of
mechanism to live but we haven't so well
that's dangerous I don't want him
alright guy who's on fire he does the
orchestra conducting finger thing when
he pees that's also like a real hassle
it's real suss
he probably can't pee in the toilet I
feel suss but if we ever lost power or
needed needed flint in the final fire we
already have fire in the form of guy
like on Survivor since this is space
survivor
we're gonna need fire and it might be
hard to make fire in space but since
he's already on fire we could cook
things over him well are we getting rid
of him no I just I just thought of that
what do you think I mean that's maybe we
could use him as a power source it's a
safety concern light source but it's
also a plus not if we locked him up what
if we kept him in an enclosure where we
could use him for heat but he could be
on fire and not touch us but like he was
cool with it
mm-hmm but where would we get that
enclosure who would build the enclosure
I don't know it would be fine okay so
our building enclosure producers do it
for us so you know like um
what's-her-face and x-men that wears the
gloves cuz when she touches people she
freezes them like it's we're just
creating a barrier between him and us
but he's okay with it
so what we're doing here by keeping him
is we're eliminating the need to have
any sort of wood or materials that we
need to throw into a fire anything
physical because we have a forever fire
mm-hmm right is that what you're saying
yeah okay I'm good with that I'm in
favor of getting rid of of useless
material like magazines which is what
you can do with texture yes it's all
digital on your phone or laptop texture
takes away all the the needless paper
magazines
it lets you have all your favorite
magazines there back issues anytime
anywhere right on your devices guys they
have all the leading magazines except
you're not going to need the useless
material of magazines when you're done
reading a magazine what do you do with
it you let it sit there and then you
reel again you hate it because you read
it already it's wasting your time get
out of here
well you have to get anywhere because
it's digital now this is the future of
magazines and it's a really awesome way
to consume content texture will give you
unlimited access unlimited to over 200
premium magazines so you can be informed
entertained inspired and you know what
just just like reading magazines that's
all you need like on a plane you can you
know just download it on texture for
offline and then there you have it okay
you'll need to buy a 10 dollar magazine
at the airport is so overpriced
I hate airports all right now guys you
can try it out for free at texture comm
slash Jenna Julian that's txt you are
EECOM slash annejulien it's a free trial
okay you see how you like it
you can choose after your free trial if
you'd like to continue for just $9.99 a
month that's over 30% off of their
listed price just for you think about
that ten dollars a month and you get
unlimited access to all those magazines
that's the price of one physical
magazine per month and you get all the
magazines it's crazy
all right guys got a texture calm slash
annejulien
start your trial nothing to lose just
give it a shot see how you like it and
let us know guys also this skin
completely free just get literally it's
a newsletter and it it is not spammy it
just sends you information in a compact
tight nice perfect form so you can just
read it and consume it it's bite-sized
content it's great especially with all
this [ __ ] you know on online news with I
mean there's a lot of bad news sites and
news news outlets and just ways to
consume news online that this is just
it's a really simple way to do it so if
you're struggling to get to the facts to
get to the headlines getting away from
the [ __ ] and the skin is what you
need okay you go to the skin calm /
Angelina that's th tsk IMM calm /
annejulien
guys it keeps you in the know about all
the the stuff
on the world good and bad okay and
there's no BS it's a newsletter right to
your email it's free so go to the skin
back on slash Anjali sign up and do your
email and click Subscribe that's
literally all you have to do and by
doing that you're gonna get the
newsletter to your email every morning
and you're also going to be enter doing
a $250 Visa gift card which you could
buy whatever you like with it except
probably illegal drugs I don't know if
that that sort of gift card works in
that scenario depends on your drug
dealer consult your drug dealer it'll be
a case-by-case basis don't listen do not
consult any drug dealer the skin does
not condone condone doing drugs although
I'm sure if you have a prescription and
you feel like you guys the scam found
solution and Julien sign up you'll be in
a shot to enjoy all gift card and you
get information here yeah are you okay
alright around myself back up look like
it one of those windup toys when you
know across the table yeah okay
so we're keeping the guy that's on fire
it's what we agreed to yes for now for
now because later on we might find that
it's a safety concern but right now [ __ ]
it we have free fire we don't have to
worry about building fires alright so
who are we getting rid of who is
providing nothing
I think Jonah Hill who doesn't believe
doctors are real people I feel like he's
just gonna cause arguments he might just
piss everyone off like that's bad for
morale
cuz what if one of these well first
we'll have a doctor we have a doctor we
have a brain surgeon I feel like they're
ready gonna fight take Jonah Hill and a
brain surgeon who runs on a hamster
wheel that potentially poses a fight
involving a human-sized hamster wheel
which could damage people and our setup
yeah and there's a guy on fire I don't
like it no Jonah I know we sound alike
goodbye okay is that good yeah I think
that the next person who was really
bothering me hmm is the sex doctor who
won't stop accusing everyone of cheating
on the test even though nobody is even
in school cause that's just super
annoying like after the first five
minutes I can't stand that okay bye
wha what if two people will start
hitting it off yeah and they're having
problems in the bedroom
and they need to consult someone about
this their sex life Julian what better
way don't have a sex dr. caner
the shows not that long to get to a
point where you can consult the sex
documentation is your problem yeah okay
you can go
I'm done with this person okay I want to
keep Jehovah's Witness on his bicycle
because I think he seems nice he's pure
yeah this is his mom I think he wants to
talk about Jesus Christ I don't think
our Lord and Savior what did they say
what they ride around on their bicycles
and they say do you have a moment to
talk about I I don't think any of its
true Julian wait what is the stereotype
of them riding around with the suits on
their bicycles I'm not sure no maybe you
didn't I don't know but look it up I
know I'm not sure where this idea being
on by some is Oh looking up a picture of
a person yes what makes you know they're
not on a bicycle yeah they are neither
of those people are on a bicycle or not
they're just people but I've seen them
are you looking up
I'm comment below that's it just comment
below what I like went to school some
Jehovah's Witnesses I thought no I'm
referring to the stereotype I'm making a
joke this is a joke of a game so I'm
making a joke that's what it was it
wasn't me being wait I saw I thought him
being on a bicycle it's like a funny
thing that you wrote I didn't know that
you thought that you know what I'm
talking about on a bike hold on do you
know what I'm talking about the person
on their bike
who's riding around and there's their
short-sleeved suit or their short-sleeve
button-down with the tie do you know I'm
sorry
no I have no idea what that is it's not
a stereotype that I just made up in my
head it's a religious person that rides
a bicycle no but the bicycle is just
part of the stereotype it's not like
it's not it's not necessary for what
they're doing it's just their means of
transportation are you talking about
like an Amish person or someone that
doesn't use like electricity or we're
too deep in this we need it back away
okay we're slowly backing away there is
no need to get any further in this
conversation
I've already dug myself pretty deep and
I don't know okay I'm already sick of
the erotic novel of saying or she what
if they start turning people on with
their work and that causes problems
that's fine they can go to the sex
doctor but we got rid of them they can't
go to the sex laughs to the sex doctors
dead it's fine okay well you know they
didn't no they're fine okay Jehovah's
Witness he has a bicycle however he's
got one he's got one yeah storage okay
that's okay big item to just keep off
you know
I'd say hamster wheels bigger than a
bicycle human-sized hamster wheel yeah
[ __ ] that guy that's so annoying so
we're getting rid of the brain surgeon
so anyone at any point needs brain
surgery we are [ __ ] yeah oh yeah
goodbye
get the [ __ ] off the planet oh all right
who else are we getting rid of I want to
get rid of the pickup artist who demands
a fortune cookie after every single meal
first of all we don't have that second
of all stop hitting on everyone all
think he's hitting on everyone he's
doing a science I don't care it annoys
me
yeah that's pretty shitty get him out
get him up out of here I don't like him
I don't like his energy I don't like
anything about it not good for our tribe
I don't like his pieces of flair drop
your buff guy your
that's your stupid torch okay
the orchestra conductor who's a flat
earther he's looking at me weird and I
don't like him still yeah we're on the
space conductor in space either like
he's not really serving a purpose nobody
needs an orchestra conductor anyway
unless you have an orchestra I mean sure
I mean maybe he's really knowledgeable
about music which would be fun to like
talk to him for a little while but then
after that he's probably just really
pretentious see I said that and then you
you said maybe that's just it maybe I'm
prejudging him and then you just did the
same thing I did
yeah we know I call myself out so now
now you call yourself out he might not
be a pretentious it's a very seasoned
boy I can't even follow this
conversation what does Aries season is
it like when the Aries month is cuz it
hasn't even started when is it I think
it's like March 20th like it's right
when your mom's birthday is right hey
Siri wondered where does Aries start the
most useless AI ya world March 21st so
we're not even there yet
it's not even my mom's birthday is the
24th she's the most arias person I know
hmm you guys wonder where I got my Aries
it's a hundred percent my mom she's the
most amazing woman but she is the air
easiest woman I've ever met
tornado tornado like I forget like the
other day and we were discussing what
we're gonna do for lunch so my brother
Marlon and I were like okay let's walk
to the grocery store we'll pick
something out and you know like one of
the pre-made meals will come back home
and eat it and she's like okay so she
goes see the room and my brother now
okay we're gonna go we put on shoes we
go to the kitchen and say goodbye to my
mom but like okay we're gonna go to her
we walk into the kitchen and she's she's
cooking pasta really wait what are you
doing she's like I'm cooking pasta for
us to eat lunch I was like we just
agreed that has gone we're gonna start
and it's like I felt like Jenna feels
90% of the time
like we just had a conversation and then
what are you doing so that's where I get
it
I'm proud to be in Aries tips my
astrological cap my Aries okay
orchestra conductor bye yeah we're not
gonna eat them by this but we don't want
ya we don't want all right the next
person who's annoying me is kylie
jenner's baby's future baby who smells
like pistachios and lies about
everything regardless of the fact that
Kylie Jenner is her grandmother to be so
perfect it'd be cool to have Kylie's
granddaughter with us just totally but
she lies about everything that's a bad
characteristic it's not a good character
he can get get up out of here yeah
you're got you're out next week gone oh
okay
so the retired porn star who doesn't
understand gravity after 10 p.m.
oh my god exhaust I have I have one
major question what 10 p.m. like what
o'clock are we going by well if we're on
another planet that has some sort of
different like morbid or a different
song oh I guess you said we're on like
near Saturn Saturn Springs it's not it's
nowhere near Saturn I don't know why I
got its name is that I thought you said
it was it was the sister planet they're
very they're very they're estranged
sisters they don't talk mm-hmm okay so
it depends on the rotation of our place
what if 10 p.m. make 20 or a full day
and then it's like 700 hours till the
next hour so we only have one right
there isn't he but so like we're stay
were there for like a few months or
something or like a month we only have
one night during that experience yeah
there's just a clueless guy told ya but
I mean we haven't really had a lot of
time to acclimate to this planet right
so he's still having 10 p.m. or she's
having 10 p.m. regardless of that it's
like jet lag but like on steroids yes
so if you're still having it regardless
of the planets or yes is the answer the
[ __ ] that person here and they're
retired point sorry I mean I feel
terrible for them but I can't have you
just forgetting how gravity works every
single night
well I'm freaking out about it yeah I
mean in the thing about the retired
points are that in and is in and of
itself it's not a bad thing but
something about them not being able to
stop reminiscing about the glory days
makes me feel okay I don't want to know
more about that what are their glory
days I don't know I'm not them but they
won't sup okay no it's his glory hole
day okay okay oh that is my blanket hey
Lou is it about here go no my alright
this person sucks an IT guy who refuses
to believe churches are real we don't
need an IT guy whatever but the next
person for me that's really starting to
get on my nerves is the youtuber who
does candle reviews but instead of
reviewing the smell they review how bad
they burn you like that when they touch
that when you touch them and then they
sleep yell and Dothraki I like that guy
I like him through and through it is
fantastic he's a model model human
because first of all that YouTube
channel it's so incredibly innovative
and outside the box you're not gonna do
it's not self harm if you ain't mad
that's what it says in the Terms of
Service ain't it ain't self harm it you
ain't no no no no no no and no oh man I
would subscribe so fast no you can't you
can't watch I just want to know if our
last candle hurts me more than an orange
spring candle I want to know it doesn't
depend on the scent of it depends on the
size of the wick and how about the flame
how do you know you don't have that
channel oh my god you can't have a
channel where you repeatedly burn
yourself well on YouTube you know what
challenge accepted Julian no 2018 is the
year that I launched my candle channel
it is 2018 2019 I'm doing there
here give me a few months no kind of
prepares this person needs to stop it
they're banned from YouTube and they're
banned from the night time because they
won't stop yelling in Dothraki okay I
concede I reluctantly concede I mean the
only way out keep them is if they just
burn themselves on burn guy and then
they can be together but then they're
gonna form an alliance how good it would
smother they're gonna form an alliance
all right fine fire based alliance that
we can't handle okay we're getting down
to the nitty-gritty here okay
the novelist who can't stop saying wig
needs to go he isn't provided addend
what they're fine what about dandruff
Parmesan dad okay he can stay I still
have a problem get down to one okay we
we have to decide right now
man we're in like that yeah tribal or
it's like we don't know why hit the
merge and we're just think the
electrician is useless what is what says
he shakes your hand with his tickling
your hand yeah he doesn't provide a
goddamn thing
goodbye okay so now we have the
Jehovah's Witness the erotic novelist
the fire guy and the divorce dad on my
side we have Michael Keaton yeah Michael
Keaton cast have stuck on you Michael
Keaton squeezing into his uh 30-year old
Batman outfit cause I'm constantly
updating our know constantly updating on
how well their stock investments are
going Matt Damon and Greg Kinnear from
stuck on you but they steal people's
toiletries uncontrollably who you've
been vouching for but I want to
eliminate every time they're a good
addition to any team and a beekeeper
who's lost his way but won't stop
talking about how cutting out caffeine
has made them feel that guy is obnoxious
it's starting to get a little get him
out of here sorry we get it all right
you're you're you're accustomed and not
having caffeine because you chose to cut
it out of your diet peach is gonna knock
over that whole monitor right now she
literally just shook that home honor all
right okay you still have a bunch left
yeah okay I've been pushing to get rid
of a rag novelist who's his wig
I think they're sweet sweet this is a
survivor humor oh no that one hurts that
one hurts wig me that one hurt that was
her and I was right
that was my closest friend in Long
Island oh it wasn't me no I mean besides
no no beside you know already said my
feelings are hurt lots are different
okay I'm all of a sudden lost my
appetite and I don't want parmesan
dandruff really yeah I need fire more
than that no no no really he's a good
source of food as long as we give him
dandruff II but he's constantly just
sleeping with everyone
he's freshly divorced wait what what
makes you think he's sleeping with
everyone
it's divorced what what he's free wait
so Savoy people sleep with everyone
jehovah's witnesses only ride bicycles
these are your stereotypes not mine okay
I've said I haven't said a word this
whole podcast about anything mm-hmm
I haven't even opened my mouth okay
that's your stereotype okay you know
because right now it's you me Michael
Keaton here who's this person a guy
who's on fire and who was that person I
was witness so he's having sex with a
Jehovah's Witness a guy who was on fire
Matt Damon Greg Kinnear and Michael
Keaton or all at the same time so am I
the only girl right now yes
no the Jehovah's Witness is a girl okay
Michael Keaton is awesome okay Michael
Keaton can go
he was my Batman I love him but he's
providing nothing but I can say that
safely that we kept them as long as we
could because he's Batman we appreciate
you Batman
thank you but good goodbye fire guy
we're keeping for now Jehovah's Witness
what are they just Jehovah's Witness
just misses his mom out goodbye
nobody's got a number of weeks with him
missing its mom yeah we get we all miss
a lot of Tyrael sir mom okay now we have
divorced dad he's Parmesan cheese hair
guys on fire who pees everywhere and
come on come on baby we got to keep this
stuck on you Matt I'm gonna read this
card again because it's so eloquently
written Matt Damon but he's in the
makeup from stuck on you so he's
attached to Greg Kinnear who
uncontrollably steals people's
toiletries so just cut to the end I know
that you want them to wait well let's
just be honest here this would be a
great great series like this would sell
so say the prize is that you win money
or something now we're splitting it but
like if they win they split it 50/50 how
do they win they have to win together
right so if you want to get rid of them
I'll allow it but I don't want Parmesan
cheese I'm sick of them I don't want to
eat any more Parmesan cheese I've eaten
it for ten weeks oh who would you rather
have win imagine that we're like in the
jury our jaw was witnessed on the who's
left fire guy guy who's on fire
absolutely not I don't want him to win
he's been on fire the whole time and
secluded from the rest of everyone else
to not catch him on fire he's barely
participated in any of the challenges
he's provided fire for the whole tribe
for weeks he's made it so no one had
ever had to build a fire so what do you
mean so you can't help but they use on
fire you shouldn't just win the show
because he's on fire he can use the
money to get looked at by a doctor and
see why he's on fire he still doesn't
know why he was with a brain surgeon the
whole time it's not a doctor that's a
brain surgeon who was awaiting the show
who's winning the show right now I say
we all I say we put our votes together
so on the count of three slam our hand
down on the table very loud and
violently this is fire guy this is Matt
Damon this is divorce dad okay yep when
you into divorce - yeah because I don't
want Matt Damon and Greg Kinnear oath
and stealing people's toilets
just fire fire guys out that determined
fire is that some that we have divorced
dad versus the cast of stuck on you in
stuck on you cost already I don't think
it's the leopard he should win show same
folks two celebrities should not be able
to win a reality show the first time in
its existence going to another planet is
[ __ ] and they stole things the
entire season love you guys
the winner oh you a survivor season one
is a freshly divorced dad with nothing
to lose whose dandruff is Parmesan
cheese congratulations to dad yeah but
think of think of the reunion he's
crying his life has changed now he is
hope after he supports his kids still
don't want to talk to him because their
mom has turned them against him but a
young nice Italian lady who is a in the
ocean for parmesan is boxin she owns a
restaurant she owns a pasta Italian food
restaurant Surya and she sees a not only
a working relationship but a sexual one
as well she wants him to put Parmesan
cheese all over her from his head while
they have sex
well good thing he met a sex doctor on
the show what a ride it's been and
didn't did thanks for watching season 1
of space survivor
we need advertisers to get to how we
funded a trip to space good well done
that was fun
that was fun space survivor good game
trademark well it like unlike nuclear
winter where you have to take people's
occupations into consideration we get to
just eliminate the most annoying people
first yeah well thank you guys for
watching uh space survivor and listening
the gingiva podcast is incredibly nice
to be back and missed you guys and we
will see you next week with another
episode and it will officially be Ares
season next week so karma just really
you can do it we stream on Twitch
all-time twitch.tv slash Jenna Julian
and check out the sponsors in the
description helps us out supports the
show
take a biker breathe into the mic take
us out dude take us out to commercials
all right goodbye
[Music]
[Music]